[Applause]
so so first of all thanks to the jayjay
Charitable Trusts and thanks to BAFTA
for having me and thanks to all of you
guys wanted to listen I have to say
standing here in the British Museum it
feels like a huge momentous occasion so
I tried to psych myself out by
pretending it wasn't a big deal on the
way over but um standing in the midst of
all these antiquities you know it didn't
work so I should let you know right away
that I have more questions and I have
answers so rather than talking on a
particular theme I thought I'd share
with you some of the questions that I
asked myself and riding in some of the
ways in which I interrogate the material
yeah so the first is we go the first
slide saying what they don't mean and so
basically people in real life rarely say
exactly what's on their mind or exactly
what they feel and they do this for a
number of reasons right so either
they're protecting the self or they're
protecting the other person and so it's
really weird and cinema when people give
these full-on heartfelt emotional
monologues you know that are
expositional and saying exactly what
they think because that's not really how
it goes in life and so I had this great
writing professor his name was Mick
Casal and so his idea was this thing
called the triple bumper theory and this
was the idea that whatever someone
really feels like back off of it three
times and then you'll get to the thing
that maybe should be on the page right
so for example right so a love scene you
know girl meets girl right so they were
they're in love so you know the thing
that is meant is I love you right but
you wouldn't say that right because
there's a risk you might be rejected so
maybe you back it off one tennis I love
your sweater
right but even that feels too risky so
you could back it off again and say
where'd you buy that sweater you know
and then if you want you could back it
off again and say I heard there's a sell
at Topshop on sweaters you know so but
and then as a director the subtext of
that I hear to the sell at Topshop is
really I love you you know
and then that comes across in the scene
the audience is smart the audience gets
it so as a writer you know you don't
want to put it exactly on the page that
way so there's that buffer there so for
you the writer you know when you're
writing dialogue there are no
consequences right and so there's a
temptation for your characters to be
these this avatar this kind of
courageous defender that goes off and
says the things that you want to say but
just you know keeping in mind that for
the character there are consequences
there's very real consequences and they
would protect themselves from that and
so yeah so rather than let characters be
your champion you have to like
understand the consequences that they're
in and kind of protect them like with
the dialogue so with that I'll actually
play the first clip and this is a scene
from pariah where Arthur Lee K's
fatherly care kind of dancing around the
truth and then we'll talk about it a bit
come on now you know that's not what I
want that's not what I'm saying just
listen to me
are you gonna listen to me dad listen I
better go I'm gonna go my daughter's my
daughter's up dad talk to you later bye
who's that she doing up just wanted to
talk
dad the plate don't trash the plate
aren't you hungry no hado ready you a to
work grab some takeout
oh we're Why ask me so many goddamn
questions girl what's wrong with you
don't question me sorry
hold up a li k come on back look I got
Patty's beef and chicken listen um your
mama's worried that
it's just warned me to ask you that
how school straight A's
probably that's right he said
I said a sip a sip
so you mind nothing
what if what if say somebody liked you
they like you or they like you like you
they liked you like you uh-huh that was
anything yet wait but what if all right
what if the person is kind of like a
friend but you know they like you more
than that
well I think that's the best way to
start mrs. friends what if what if the
person is what's her name what grade is
in I'm lucky this I've been a system
wait till I tell your mama she'll be so
goddamn happy yeah
say there's this new Women's Club up
there by the liquor store do you have
you you haven't heard anything about it
right called the kitty litter cat box
something like that no and never even
heard of it
good cuz it's uh that's a rough
neighborhood you know that right I had a
case over there you want to be careful
stay away from that element in case it
ever comes up I'll be careful
good I know you will
dad when you on the phone earlier it
sounded like I mean I guess you're
headed back to work huh yep
your mama's still up probably tell her I
had to worm
love you
cool so so that's like a three or four
part scene right so the first part of
the scene is like this kind of
confrontation you know so we see this
characters constantly kind of advancing
and retreating from each other so in the
first part is a confrontation of Lika is
confronting our Father who's obviously
having an affair you know but she can't
quite prick him with it you know he kind
of bats her away and says why are you
questioning me so then the scene turns
right and so this Arthas turned to
advance Oh your mom wants me to ask you
silly tiptoes up to the line you know
and he really wants to ask the fight of
sexuality and then he retreats you know
and doesn't do it and then in the end
Lee Kate goes back again and like she
advances to the line and you know and so
going to the triple bumper theory for
example right in the beginning of the
scenery throws away the plate
you know Leah's I mean Alika is not that
concerned about her mother's you know
Tupperware I mean she's more concerned
about the marriage so it's like dad
you're going at the plate it's more like
dad you're throwing away us or dad
you're throwing away the marriage or dad
you're throwing away the relationship
you know don't you want the relationship
and so that's an example of like an
object kind of standing in for like the
real thing
that the character wants to talk about
and you know when we're talking about
consequences earlier so people say
things or don't say things either
because they want to avoid something or
because they want something to happen
and so the scene is this dance of
avoidance right and so when you're
writing you're asking like well what are
your characters avoiding and so for the
father our third he knows his daughters
as gay is gay but he's avoiding kind of
like the direct knowledge of that
because to him that means things have to
change and so Arthur's main Drive when I
was directing is to maintain the status
quo so he wants to not know so things
can stay the same and with Allie K right
she doesn't want to know that her
father's cheating although she knows
he's cheating why like what are the
consequences cuz the consequences of
that knowledge means that she has to
hurt her mother because if she knows and
she has to say something to her mother
and so she's like avoiding you know
hurting her mother and so that's the
kind of that's part of the dance in that
scene and so you know in the end you
know there's kind of like consummation
of this very big they agree to keep each
other secrets like the sip of beer
becomes this kind of like consummation
of we're both not going to say you
the subversive thing that happens and
and and so all of that as a director
you're working into the plot and also in
blocking so like when we go into the
third part of the scene where the [ __ ]
tries to kind of confront once more I
have them facing away from each other
because sometimes easier to say things
you're not looking at someone so it's
just like something to think about as
you know you're writing and dealing with
the truth and avoidance and all that
good stuff another example of this will
be my phone Bessie and so it's example
same kind of thing and instead of saying
what they don't mean in this clip people
are like avoiding saying the thing so in
this scene my conception is viola is
saying you owe me and Bessie is saying
you don't owe me and we play out that
dialogue we play out that kind of
unspoken dialogue through their action
so we'll see the second clue they said
you had your own train I didn't believe
okay dance this you hide pose now uh-huh
you ain't telling me about all this you
get that money I sent you oh yeah
I get them little wires you be sending
your nice say eating for kids and all
[Music]
okay look I know you wouldn't I bump
heads most of the time well I'm just
here to show my support mmm real nice
this from Europe and what have you
I got you something probably not fancy
enough for you now I thought you liked
it
I'm proud of you I'm so proud of you
you're gonna stay around for a while
think clams could give me tickets he in
the box-office
so we can stop that one there yeah oh
yeah it's a trap that's what's in the
package yeah so here's an example right
so you know in context of the rest of
the movie like we rarely see Bessie
hesitant or afraid right and so you know
she's the baby sister but she's still
you when she comes into contact with
viola viola is like on her turf I was
taking up her territory she's trying on
her makeup using her things you know so
there's a hostility in that right these
are my things and and and this is the
first time we see Bessie kind of on her
heels and so you know we're saying so
much in this weave there's a guilt in
that like Bessie feels guilty about what
she has she she's afraid of Viola she
may be some part of her believes that
she does owe Viola because Viola hasn't
had the life that she's had and she took
care of her as a child and so all that's
playing out in the blocking in the body
language and then Bessie coming to take
back her territory
you know the subtle threat with the
scissors or maybe not so subtle but you
know there's this kind of idea where
like Bessie is gonna like reclaim her
space she's I'm like reclaim her her
area but even when she does reclaim her
territory viola even though she's
diminutive still has like this hold over
her and so that's another example of
kind of people not saying what they mean
and that I'm proud of you obviously
that's like the opposite of what she
means and so yeah that all right so the
next thing is a narrative lyricism and
so this is about you know separating
your voice as a writer from the voice as
a character and so I think we're like
first-time filmmakers even second time
filmmakers as a tendency to like make
your character an artist or a writer I
did it I know I did and and you know why
do people do that they do that because
then the characters an even better
vessel for your like you know right
early you know poetic kind of things
that you want to say but it kind of goes
back to the first point about not making
the character in avatar for your voice
but if your character does have an
artistic voice if there is a lyricism to
their language like how do you separate
it out how you make sure that this poem
is coming from them or this thought is
coming from them and not just coming
from you like how do you translate it
into the characters kind of terms and
I would say that in blending your voice
with the character's voice you know be
mindful like like what is your
characters like a scope of experiences
like if you're a 40 year old
screenwriters travel the world and
you're writing a 17 year old woman who's
never left Brooklyn you know then
automatically you have to be careful of
your references even in lyrics like you
can't reference things that they
wouldn't say nor and even in terms of
like fears like the thing that you fear
like aging or loneliness or death it may
not be the thing that your characters
fears so when you're crafting poetry for
them or crafting things for them like
what is it they're afraid of what is it
that they desire and try not to transp
on your own desires onto your characters
and I would also say like disfiguring
like your characters like reference
points of the world like you know
people's worlds tend to be I think
routine and small in a way and so how
they come how they compose metaphors
about their life is based on things that
they've seen or experienced so I'll the
next clip is from pariah so it's the end
poem and actually I didn't want to write
this poem when we were in the production
of it because I felt like Oh it'll be
corny this will be yet another film
where the protagonist artists and
delivers this poem in the end I don't
want to do it
and my editor Michael commits and was
like oh just like write something like
just bright it record if you hate it we
won't use it and so for prior we had
like one day of pickups we had to shoot
the rooftop scene between Ali and her
father because it was snowing the first
I the first time we tried to shoot it's
way to come back and get it when it
wasn't snowing
it was the same physical location as
where he shot the classroom location so
I wrote this poem on a napkin at a
Starbucks and then we you know popped
down and shot it and I'm glad we did but
this is the thing I was struggling with
and like afraid of was about what was my
voice was Ali Kay's voice and so yeah so
we'll see that heartbreak opens on to
the sunrise
for even breaking is opening and I am
broken I'm open
broke into the new light without pushing
in open to the possibilities within
pushing out see the love shine in
through my cracks see the light shine
out through me I am broken I am open I
am broken open see the love light
shining through me shining through my
cracks do the gaps my spirit takes
journey my spirit takes flight could not
have risen otherwise and I'm not running
I am choosing
running is not a choice from the
breaking breaking is freeing broken is
freedom
I'm not broken I'm free
yeah
yeah
so that ways chokes me up so it's
probably little more my voice and Ali
K's voice but um but that's that's an
example in um I would say you know also
between characters each character has
their own separate vocabulary even
people who live in the same household
even people who are best friends even
people of the same you know nationality
like people have their own kind of
favorite words and things that they
reuse and so even when characters are in
a similar Malou or similar circumstance
it's important to kind of separate their
voice from each other so as an example
that will we'll play let's skip to clip
three for mudbone haps monologue and
we'll then we'll go back in here rounds
out in Florence to hear how even within
a family the voices can be different
well good is a be my grandfathers and
great uncles grandmothers and great off
father and mother broke till o planet
club raise bond
broke again work this land all day life
this land that never would be this they
worked until they sweated they sweated
until they bled they bleed until he died
died with the dirt of this same 200
acres on the day Shingen s died crawling
at the heart Brownback that would never
be there all day B's undone yet this man
this place this law say you need a deed
not deeds yeah so this is like so happy
is a sharecropper right so then he's
gonna have like a limited you know
amount of education and his thing you
know this is a time where like
illiteracy was the law now say again
illiteracy was the law it was against
the law for black people to be literate
but within that he can have a kind of
he can have a kind of thinking about the
land and he can have a meditation but
you know I'm writing for him so I'm
interested in like the way he formed
sentences differently you know father
and mother you know instead of mother
and father so just like ways you can
break the conventional like when you're
writing for another character in like
ways that they would speak that you may
not speak and even like you know of
course like subject verb agreement and
tenses it's about how it feels how that
character would express themself but
even expressing themselves in a limited
way or within kind of like a narrow
context can be graceful and can be
elegant and so now we'll play the second
clip where we hear a little bit of Ron
Zell and then it hands off to Florence's
voiceover you just come back come all
the way back oh I love you too babe
[Music]
I can't
I didn't look back they say it's bad
luck to watch somebody
I held his heartbeat in my head I
remember every beat
he was warm and alive I know every place
in him and it was all I could do to not
look back you know I don't have
favorites
I loved him all evening every mother
does but during all those four years all
that time he was gone I only pray for
him
God will forgive me until the last line
that is God will forgive me but just
even between like Florence and HAP
there's like a different and a
difference in how they use language like
hers it's like a little more oldie like
you know like almost like from the Bible
it's like biblical the way she speaks
you know and it's like a little crisper
you know so you know imagine that Flair
that Florence comes from a different
mother and father than half comes from
so idiom sayings things they believe
will be different even though they're
now joined in the same household
so the stupid metaphor I wrote for this
was um nobody you know even though it
might may be the same cuisine like
nobody cooks their pot of beans the same
way you know so it's kind of like
Florence wait Florence cooks it
something different from similarly HAP
cooks it even though it's the same
recipe so that yeah and then also
voiceover you know I think can reveal a
characters in her life like fast when
it's like most interesting and you know
when it's not about what's literally
happening on the screen when it's more
philosophical when it's about how they
feel what's the thing that they won't
say to someone else and the inner
monologue yeah it's like the thing they
would never say to others and so for
this film for mudbone we actually cut a
lot of things we recorded because it was
to just kind of expositional and what
was happening and so yeah and so I made
that point to say so in HAP's monologue
there's like a bitterness not a
bitterness but there's a fatigue there's
like a cynicism there's like a kind of
doubt about this endeavor that he would
never Express
to his wife to his sons in front of them
he's relentless he's optimistic we're
gonna make it we're gonna make it but in
his mind he can be what good is a deed
you know so it's just a character
relevant Tori thing where he's keeping
up this front for his family but inside
he feels that he's rolling a rock uphill
so then we'll go to the last group which
is look at me so this is about spectacle
and so you know Aristotle kind of lists
spectacle as like the least important of
the six elements of drama and I think
that spectacle you know sometimes is
misused you know in terms of like you
know standing in for a lack of feeling
or standing in for lack of character
development but I think all the best
things start with spectacle like like
Romeo and Juliet starts with a murder
actually so I like spectacle and I think
when used smartly you can actually use
it to reveal character right and
spectacle so then becomes useful for
introductions and for turning points so
we're first meeting a character or when
the character is coming something else
or change into something new so it's a
way to kind of like combine you know
this extraordinary kind of sight and
sound with a turning point inside
someone's life so then the Speck
spectacle becomes meaningful and we get
like external visualizations of this
person's kind of mind change or you get
an external visualization of someone's
like personality so to that point
actually yeah we'll play the opening
sequence of pariah clip to all you
ladies pop your [ __ ] like this shake
your body don't stop don't miss all you
ladies pop your [ __ ] like this shake
your body don't stop just do it do it do
it
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you walking with you cool yeah
so a leak a so the opening music you
hear and watching this film is my neck
my back my [ __ ] I my crack so that's
like audio this auditory shocking you
know it's like spectacle in a way it's
like oh my god like what are we in for
and so but it's not just shock for shock
value sake it's introducing a leak a as
someone who's not comfortable in this
hyper sexualized environment you know
she's a chameleon and a loner so by the
end of the scene like she obviously
wants to be in this place because we've
watched her get here but then she's kind
of like both attracted and repulsed by
you know the sexuality on display and so
on the opening scene without her saying
you know Morgan a sentence we get that
she's like you know a chameleon she's a
loner she's someone who is sexual but
not yet comfortable in her sexuality
and so then the next thing the last
thing I'll play for you is use of
spectacle as like a turning point and so
this will be the Bessie clip
[Applause]
[Music]
good day
[Applause]
reach
six months
now
minibar
[Applause]
Tim
[Applause]
convert
[Applause]
[Music]
see this is a turning point for Bessie
so this is the point where she's kind of
gone from like singer to folk hero so
just before this moment she's run off
the Ku Klux Klan with an axe and so you
know for her this is like an
unintentional transition she's not
trying to be their hero but this is a
moment she's anointed her hero and where
her music becomes freeing her music
becomes a sermon her music you know not
only she's preaching to women about
liberating their sexuality but she's
also you know showing activism like
autonomy like the show did not get shut
down it didn't burn the tent this kind
of courage in the face to fear and so
this is a good use of spectacle like
yeah it's you know fun dance number and
there's music and singing but the bigger
thing that's happening is that Bessie is
now elevated from like you know signo to
hero so that's all I have
[Applause]
up to the audience um thank you so much
I wanted to talk about catharsis in a
way in terms of it's something that runs
through all three of your features
through the characters all of them with
pirates a girl navigating her way
through creative talents her sexuality
with besties through her own demons to
fame and in mudbone you see it through
everyone's narratives in terms of being
a writer and the idea of catharsis how
much do you give more of yourself than
you get back from it yeah I would say I
think I probably get more catharsis out
of it than the characters is that the
question or the characters are for
myself in both ways but yeah yeah I
think I definitely think like the first
thing I told you like don't make the
characters your champion like okay I
kind of do that anyway but like I'm I
try to do in the way that's like
realistic and in a way when a weak a
stands up to her father you know and
when she tells her mother you know I
love you you know like that was a
reflection of like a lot of what I was
going through at the moment it was the
things the conversations I had had with
people or the conversations I wanted to
say and Lee K said things for me like
that I didn't so I feel like in that way
through the characters catharsis like
the audience should have an emotional
feeling so it's not just about me the
creator but the audience hopefully
there's a catharsis for the audience or
the audience feels or cries or laughs
you know that that's kind of like the
ultimate goal so yeah and in terms of
the film's the subject matters you don't
go in big and wide it's not trying to
attack a huge experience and through
kind of trying to tackle in on something
collective you go very person you manage
to tackle race and gender and sexuality
and are you very consciously you want to
write stories about human relationships
and those narratives and the way people
communicate with each other rather than
making an issue based yeah I think I'm
interested in like people interrogating
the self like people's kind of like
either obliviousness to their selfhood
or questioning of their selfhood like
you know characters who are lonely or
you lonely or isolated or feel isolated
I think I'm drawn to that thematically
and like you know journalist like raised
it to me I hadn't you know I guess it's
all like subconsciously happening but I
like a lot of my like family
relationships tend to be unsafe you know
or the friendships tend to be tense you
know and so I think that probably comes
across and those are the kind of themes
I'm kind of drawn to so in pariah
Lara's her best friend but Lara's
tugging her to be something that she's
not so there's a tension and there's the
other tension of Laura being in love
with her and then in Betsey you know you
know that seemed like Bessie just wants
her sister to be proud of her to really
be happy for but her sister feels like
she does always need something from her
so you know and like when Bessie you
know when I was researching her
biography like I was most taken by the
fact that when she went home is when she
got stabbed you know if she had just
stayed on the road you know she would
have been fine and then in mud bound you
know like Ron Zell you know doesn't want
to go back home and can never go back
home in a way you know from the father
like I didn't know you smoked you know
so like I always kind of drawn to that
kind of inability to go back home and
when home is not safe for family
relationships I think that's the thing
I'm always exploring and each of those
characters from like a leak aide to
Bessie - like Ron Zell and the and even
like the McCallum's like like that all
those characters they're kind of like
questioning themselves and and and how
you know the world how they're affecting
the world around them or how they feel
they're not able to affect the world
around them and then kind of a maybe
question yourself you go back to pariah
it initially started off as a 30 minute
short film did you write it originally
as ash or did you write it as a future
so prior I wrote as a feature I wrote it
as like a hundred forty page feature it
was before I knew any better that
feature strip shouldn't be 140 pages but
but it was that and I had her going to
college and like going to frat parties
it was like awful so it started as this
like bloated draft of a script and then
I realized that to tell it well I could
only tell that part of her experience
that kind of high school moment over the
course of a couple of months versus
trying to like span so much time with
his characters awareness because I had
her like learning and unlearning making
mistakes over it again and while
repetition I think happens in life I
think we make the mistakes over and over
until we don't you know in in cinema or
in drama you
we have to kind of find you have to kind
of illustrate that you know with a
brevity of kind of like experiences or a
comparative moments and so so probably
started as a feature and then I needed a
thesis to graduate from NYU and I was
obsessed with this I couldn't think of
anything else I shot the first act as a
short film and then the short and which
by the way it was against all the rules
they said you know don't make up half
our short film it'll never get
programmed because then that means you
got to be as good as three films you
know to even like get considered but I
did anyway and the great thing is like
they would always program us last so we
would be like either first or last name
program because we're so long but you
know the short then kind of made the way
to raise funds for the feature film so
I've written this feature script just
bloated you know workshop it at the
Sundance labs and then we shot the
feature and then we use the short to
kind of finance the feature as can
became our calling card a part of that
short they included you cleared part to
the short in the future then so we
reused the bus sequence because getting
MTA bus from New York City is like hell
and so I was like there's no way we're
gonna run another bus so we reused the
bus scene we reuse some of the club
scenes so it was extremely like low
budget we shot pry for like four hundred
seven thousand dollars and we never had
all that money in the bank at the same
time and so we totally like reused you
know some of the short that we could but
we had recast so for the father and went
with Charles Parnell first of the short
was like window piers and like the
mother so we like recast the parents
completely but I wanted to keep the
girls the same so we use what we could
but we use we mostly we shot it and then
there was obviously a little critical
success for prayut did well you managed
to then move on to Bessie so you've gone
on for a completely original screenplay
to then alter by a biographical was
Bessie story something you always had in
mind you always when I tell Bessie Smith
story or how did that come about
it wasn't so prized 2011 and invest he's
like 2015 so in that four-year gap I was
like writing many things that didn't get
produced
so when focus acquired pariah they'd
give me a blind script deal to write a
crime thriller and so I'd wanted to do
next this kind of crime thriller about
this detective based in Memphis and she
was like a lesbian detective and you
know so focus that okay the script is
too small for us but if you can find the
money we'll give it back to you and so
they so we're then
these independent investors I said okay
we'll make this if you cast it in a way
that makes sense for the foreign sales
value equation and so you know of course
and other people that I want to cast
like fit the foreign sales by your
equation and then the two people who did
fit the foreign sales by equation the
women I went out to said oh I'm sorry I
don't want to be a lesbian so it was
just interesting so it was and so that
was like two years of a film not
happening so then that's 2011 to 2013
and then you know I also had written
spec pilot for the spec pilot about
Nashville like wanted to tell the story
about my in my hometown so I'm shopping
the spec script around you know I'm
gonna tell the story about Nashville and
everyone's like you know my agent like
no one wants a story about Nashville and
then like six months later comes out
there's like a [ __ ] series called
Nashville yeah so that's like been a
year of like walking around with
something that's not working but in the
course of that this this little speck
scrip had gotten all around town ever
seen it's great it's great it's great we
don't want to do it and so but um HBO
had because I pitched it to them like
twice and so you know they had and they
said well do you want to like we've had
the script we got it from another studio
it's called Bessie do you want it like
we're looking for someone to do like a
rewrite on it and like would you be
interested and I was like Bessie Smith
like queer woman from Tennessee like
hell yeah I want to write this script
you know and I wanted to rewrite it if I
could make her queer if I could talk
about my rainy if I could talk about you
know how the blues women sexually and
economically empowered other women and
so that was again like my reason to come
on so I could inject my own kind of
agenda into the material so I rewrote
the script and another directors
originally attached by I rewrote it so
specifically and so weirdly they're just
like what do you like no one else can
direct this do you want to direct this
and so I was like yeah so evil plan pays
off so southern that's how 2015 I came
to direct Bessie and then yeah so I
forgot the question but that's how it
was there somewhere but that's how that
came to be yeah and then when you're
writing obviously from 2000 and 2015
you've been writing multiple things how
I just want to get down to the nitty
gritty of kind of you at home writing
how are you focusing on something
different every single day you like
actually I'm going to go to that TV show
today I'm going to go to that film today
this one I focus on or is it
project-by-project
there's a research method to it or how
does your mind work when it comes to the
actual sitting at the desk
it's kind of project by project so for
the spec TV pilot I was writing like I I
was writing that while we're in the edit
of pariah you know like I was like this
is burning simmering ideal like I got to
get this out so I was like right II I
wrote that pilot like two weeks you know
so I was like writing that while we're
cutting and then for Bessie is a lot of
research it was daunting because this is
someone's life in his actual facts so
facts are harder to work with because
you have to like you know be accurate so
I researched much more of course for
that that I would and for Bessie there's
not a lot of visual record other than
promotional photos and there's one video
clip for her so I was really trying to
get a sense of her as a character and so
I ended up finding my way in my way into
her through her music so I figured the
best way to know what artist is to like
listen closely to her art so it's
listening very closely to her work and
I'd wanted to not just play the hits not
just pigfoot and bottle of beer but I
wanted the songs that were hits that the
songs that maybe got deeply into her
psyche so like for example we open the
film with young women's blues and so
it's a declaration of self like I'm you
know I'm not gonna back down I'm
beautiful I'm strong even though the
character may not quite believe that so
I wanted to open the film of that song
because it's this kind of statement of
like the desired self you know this not
the real self and even to preaching the
blues like I chose that song because
again it's about this like she's talking
you know about like sexuality and this
kind of like you know feminist way you
know before there's really a name for
that and so you know I want I found my
way in the Bessey's character through
her music look okay she's about women
she's about you know she's depressed you
know and so I there's a there's other
songs like Spider Man's blues like that
I didn't put in there but I wanted to
choose my way into her characters I was
like researching her lyrics and really
trying to see what she was really saying
again understanding that like what she
would perform would be very different
than like the recorded lyrics that we
have and and when she would the things
that she recorded for record companies
would be like taken down or code of a
bit right she was more radical in her
tent shows than she was in her
recordings because in her recording she
couldn't like call white people out
directly but she could talk around it
and so that was my process for that and
also there's this Broadway album one
more time by this guy of Vernon
who did he's a well-known choreographer
and composer and so he done this
Broadway recording and I remember as a
kid my grandma couldn't play it for me
and we'd listen to it and I put socks on
my hands like gloves we dance around the
living room to this kind of like brought
these broadway covers of like you know
old like vaudeville songs and Bessie
songs and so that was my way in I drink
gin for a time to try it in like think
of like that was her drinks I thought
maybe if I'd like whiskey's my drink but
she drinks gin so I said maybe I'll
switch to jazz it to gin and see if that
puts me a different mood or headspace
yeah
and then for mud bound it was more like
you know interrogating my own personal
history and I thought of things that
didn't ask my grandfather's like one
went to Korea one went to World War two
and so it was kind of trying to get into
my grandmother's psyche and her journals
and her memories and injecting that into
the script like shamelessly injecting
that experience into this and that being
the thing I really wanted to talk about
you know and kind of superimposing it on
this material so as we've got up to my
bad just wanted to skip it slightly back
to the notion of female sexuality that
you mentioned Bessie and it runs through
everything it runs through prior it runs
through my band and obviously as you
mentioning Bessie it's not an
overarching theme but it's something
that's present and people are so scared
weirdly in cinema to see female
sexuality and see desire but it's
something that we all have and that you
know every human being experiences you
conscious that that you've put that in
really just if you've written that
interest because it's a human experience
number kaitos I'm like aware of that so
one of the things from the book so in
the original script there wasn't a
moment of like you know Henry rejecting
Laura sexually but I wanted that because
she has this line based like it wasn't
that great but you know the thing we had
and made me feel like a wife so I like
that because that's like a feminist
thing to say like to say that I I Who am
supposed to be grateful for this
last-minute marriage I'm not satisfied
by this marriage and the sex isn't good
you know and so you know saying that
aloud was like a radical thing and so I
wanted that on camera where Henry bats
her away and she's like you know it's
not that good anyway you know yeah yeah
I have a lot of questions that matter
but I'm conscience that these guys have
them as well so if you do please put
your hand up and we'll get a microphone
to you happy Thanksgiving guys I'm
supposed to ask question about my brown
no there's a lot of different shifts in
archetypes during like in terms of the
characters how much room did you allow
for actors to find something that wasn't
in script and in your writing process
how did you manage to maneuver all those
arcs without them going over each other
yeah so mud bound is they're pretty much
on book you know they're pretty much on
script for most of this you know it's
like there's more performance like the
challenge is like throwing it away like
how do you not hear the script and so
like there's moments for example where
I'll like sometimes like shout things
out or like or like you know add a
little motion so for example like when
Jamie and run Zilla in the truck and
he's telling the story about you know
pissing in his helmet you know I'm in
the back of a truck and shout out the
line I thought it was hit and so he says
I thought I was hit you know so - like
you know activate that whole thing and
make it funnier so I'm open to like ads
onset mud bomb they're basically on book
and you know it's in the delivery that
kind of breaks it up and makes it not so
Reedy and like for example like another
examples like Ron Zell and the general
store with the staredown with Pappy you
know I was tempted to kind of throw away
those last lines where he says I was
over there fight and you're home safe
and sound cuz I felt like there's no way
that he can say that to pappy full in
his face cuz we just roll credits right
now like that'd be it you know but um so
I was tempted to throw it away
and the actors fought for it Jonathan
fake said no no I want him to say it and
just like no no I want to say it so I
changed the blocking like okay if you
say that you have to say it as you're
walking away and you have to say it
under your breath because if you can
give them that speech full to his face
you know then that means that there's no
problem here or you're gonna be dead you
know but so you know I changed the
blocking event to make the words work
and there's there's tons of voiceover
that we recorded
ended up throwing away and then some
voice of our wrote during post because
you know the things we through 8 felt
like he was an expositional was saying
what we're already seeing and wasn't as
philosophical and then things we added
were things that were you know not
necessarily things that we had planned
for in production but in the Edit where
I felt there were gaps and like we
weren't able to hand off things
thematically where I wrote new monologue
so that it became more thematic and not
just chronological so that kind of your
question or sometimes even actually I'll
start out so for example actually like
when the scene where Jamie and Pappy and
Henry are drinking liquor it's like his
first night back it's like sometimes
I'll give actors other dialogue or let
them improv off-book to get into it so
like I think I told Jamie like tell a
dirty joke you know so and that's the
last thing she said that's the end of
like a dirty joke and then they get into
they get into like the book you know or
get get on script so anything that kind
of eases them like we've some time you
need like an entry ramp under the
material and all that actors have that
kind of entry rap of improving but then
we get into the words you know and yeah
how did you create that intimacy between
them because it's always you can tell
it's goes back to your first slide of
subtext and so there's so much that's
not said between them but it's said but
there's because it's a level of comfort
between the actors and how did you work
with them to create that level of
intimacy so when we get to points like
this you they can refer to each other in
that sense efficiently yeah I would say
so my process with actors is not to
rehearse the lines is just to pair them
off and twos or threes and just kind of
talk about the core that relationships
like the feeling so for mudbone I had
Jonathan banks Garrett Hedlund Jason
Jason Clark who's in my office and just
like a father son and kind of like mosh
pit so you know for me the core that
whole triangle was about admiration or
respect and so this is a son of sons
these are sons who want the respect and
love of their father and this is a
father who just wants the respect and
love of his sons he doesn't wake up
every morning and say I'm gonna be a
villain today he wakes up and says you
know I want to be proud of my sons and
you know by picking at them I'm gonna
make them right you know and so I had
them just try to say something so that
was the thing as already in the script
are in the script is gonna be this
antagonism
so in the workshop I wanted to do the
opposite like I wanted to find the love
and I wanted to find the warmth like say
one thing good about your sons say one
thing good about your father
so then underneath that there's a little
blush like there's a little you know
there's got to be a little warm blood
you know can't just be playing the
straight thing and and luckily also
Garrett Hedlund and Jason Clark they
actually elected instead of flying
straight to Seth they elected to like
roadtrip down together so they could
build that in brotherly rapport so they
flew into Memphis I think and then drove
down to New Orleans and so they you know
got matching back tattoos probably but
they if they were able to like you know
kind of ease into it and like build this
kind of rapport in this ease and just
look at each other and smell each other
and be seen you know so yeah my
questions are not bound as well I saw
two dozen Film Festival easily the best
film there I'm sure it's gonna be
nominated for some Oscars but also
they're what I find it very interesting
was this four stories going on at the
same time and they're all gradually in
interlinking threat it's right as the
film went on and on which I found quite
interesting what to say so the
interlinking stories the vasa conceit of
the book so the book is structured where
each character has a chapter each
character speaks and the book that's how
it's set up where each one hands off to
the other so that was one of the
attractions in the material and the in
the Edit you know something that we had
to work hard to maintain or to make make
sense you know and in so how we edited
the film is very different than how you
know it was written and did very
different in how we shot it but the
multiple points of view I can't take
credit for it that was Hilary's idea and
it's not like a new idea like you know
isabel wilkerson does and warmth of
other Suns and nonfiction and yeah this
is not a new conceit but it's always
hard because the risk is in letting
everyone to speak you know you hear no
one so the question yes I didn't know
that I thought actually the script was
written that way so I read the book at
all yes I thought what that's very
clever scripting them to integrating
everything as the film goes on and on
I wish I could take credit for it now
that was really response truck yeah was
it biased in a way that you've changed
though yeah I would say the first draft
of the script is more away to tour the
McCallum family and you know at the
original script the point of their
connection with
girl can sing Lily made the one who was
to be a stenographer and like Laura
plays the piano so they have it's like
sweet piano singing session and for me I
just wanted to make each of the
characters connected beyond something
that was circumstantial so rather than
power outage yeah and rather than I've
got this piano you little girl can sing
I want it to be about you know these
husband's connected by disinheritance
you know HAP literally has Blood Bones
and sisters in the ground but he can't
take title to it and Henry feels
disinherited because Pappy's soul weight
was supposed to be his and for the two
wives they're connected by not just my
motherhood by by economic disempowerment
they both have husbands that tell them
what to do or not to do with the money
and both wives were disobedient they do
what they want to do anyway and then
they - exactly and then the two sons are
connected rondell and Jamie by PTSD
before there's a name for so I wanted to
so I definitely waited this the film
more fifty fifty so it's Jackson's and
McCown so we see that each person is
fighting on their own front and it's not
one kind of existing to serve the other
he first of all thank you for an
absolutely wonderful wonderful lecture
um I want to just ask about structure of
screenplays and how you deal with the
cinematic element there are some moments
in my band are exquisitely detailed like
the brother when his younger brother
takes his fiancee for a dance
he simply readjusts a piece of cloth on
the top do you write that or is that an
improvised moment because it's so
exquisitely detailed and tells us so
much about his vulnerability in his
inability to as you say at the beginning
to express that it's the three degrees
how much of this cinematic element the
descriptive element is in the script and
how much is a development through the
editing etc thank you for noticing thank
you you're the only person who noticed
our wonderful moment yeah exactly so so
that was a moment I found onset so it
was like you know she leaves and leaves
her scarf and so you know it's like that
scarf is Laura like you're loving Laura
you're giving her this touch
you know I just saw them set and
prompted the actor to do it so like this
care for this scarf is him caretaking
for his wife and trying to not feel her
absence like exactly that yeah so I
think definitely as a director you find
those things on set and there's other
things that are scripted so for example
like the first kind of talks with
producers in addition to like scenes I
wanted to write I wrote like imagery I
wanted to write like Laura chilling
calluses off her hands child eating dirt
kids playing soldier you know so these
are images that weren't necessarily the
script but they're images that I wanted
to shoot to be a part of the world like
set a tone even like the dead things
like the dead things I don't know if
it's in the script but it's like I knew
I wanted to bring forth Laura's
voiceover of like you know basically how
about country violence and so we're
shooting dead things to kind of activate
that but yeah but moments like that
that's inside the thing I can't love
Laura somewhat I love the scarf that she
had on and give obex for like he gave
her that scarf for your anniversary
so he's like securing himself also like
okay not to worry like we're still here
so yeah exactly that thank you for the
first person that notice that and got
that thank you I feel vindicated thank
you mud fun in achieving the
authenticity in those voiceovers you had
a special way of kind of recording those
and working with the actors to achieve
that so they kind of retained truth and
how did you and work with them for their
voiceovers so so I wanted them so I had
them record their voice overs on set
which every sound technician will tell
you not to do because they'll say it's
dirty you'll have unwanted you know
broom tone blah blah blah but I wanted
to record the voiceovers on set because
the actors are still in costume they're
still sweaty they're still dirty they
still hurt and they're still their dress
up from the emotion that they just kind
of experienced and so I wanted to record
their voiceovers in that state versus
letting them shower go home and come
back six months later and do it in a
sound booth where they're gonna be
distanced from the moment and trying to
summon a feeling you know it feel
contrived and a credit to our sound
recordist put kuszak she got us this
amazingly clear sound where you know we
used mostly what we shot on set there
are very few replacements and I think
it's a service to the actors to like get
their best performance and so to me I'm
failing them if I'm not putting them in
putting them in a situation to give
their best performance and so you know
taking the five minutes after a scene or
two minutes after a scene to record
something or even going to like a rental
car parked outside and give it as like
worth the five minutes of holding the
work or is worth the three minutes to
run to the car and do it just because it
allows them to give their best you know
I thank you for the lecture and your
amazing work I've got a question on
genre because it sounds like you've
written across quite a few genres from
crime detective you know you've got
historical epic dramas and very family
based dramas and you also did a philip k
dick
piece for TV as well so there's quite a
range is there any particular genre that
you find yourself most at home to or
coming back to or any difficulties
writing in a particular genre or style
no I'm always I'm always chasing story
and characters and like I'm actually
drawn to sci-fi so again I've been
trying to decipher for a while and so a
little back story of how that came to be
was I wrote an adaptation of Philip
Marshall Timeslips so I was friendly
with ISA hack it was like yes you can
have this book and do adaptation like on
spec and so you know they wanted some
rewrites but at the same time Betty came
through so I had to like leave that and
go do Bessie but we stayed friendly you
know throughout the process and she was
like hey we're doing this anthology do
you want to adapt an episode of course
you know so for me like sci-fi it's been
the thing I'm always wanted to get to
because I feel like you can actually say
more and you can be more direct because
people don't realize what they're
looking at quite you know so you could
actually be more on the nose and weird
with sci-fi and also sci-fi I think is
more dense or intense maybe because it's
like world world creation so coming up
with the logic overworld or coming up
with the luggage of the logic of like a
language like the costumes how people
speak the idioms like you know we have
to almost invent a whole new vocabulary
and invent you know you have to invent
it's like world world creation so like
it's what I'm really
most excited by and want to get into but
for me like I'm chasing characters and
ideas no matter what genre they fall
into I'll probably never do a romance I
said one genre I can't stand but like
yeah other than that yeah watch me do a
romance next year is that the key do you
think to have having object long I can
never say the word to to writing in
terms of not being shown recipie and
just writing stories about people you
want to write them to them placement
scenarios like a sci-fi situation is
that what you've always stood by in
terms of picking what you want to work
on yeah so I think of like I probably
compromised a couple of times right when
I first started out I was like I'm on
our tour I only want to do only my
original stuff no adaptations you know
instilled in a course and I compromised
so so okay well I will do adaptations
but only about stuff that I love and
like I thought that you know for me I've
always wanted to work across like
features in TV so that wasn't a thing
but I think you know in chasing like
characters and stories that I'm
interested in that means I'll cross
genres you know and that means that I
will cross like I want to get back to
more original stuff so after this I'm
gonna do it Jone did he that adaptation
with casseon but after this I want to
get back to solely like original stuff
and just like world creation but yeah I
think it's and I think I've had to be
choosy like I don't I never want to be a
director for hire
I didn't want to be just like you know
on loan to different studios directing
someone else's idea like if I fail I
want to fail on my own ideas you know so
I'd rather try to put forward the thing
I want to do or put forward the idea I
have and you know time is short like
each film eats like three years of your
life so I feel like the clock is ticking
and so I just want to you know from now
on like I'm gonna go out like go out you
know trying to do my own stuff so
[Applause]
two more questions
hi I'm be Manzini good to see you again
d we met at the after party for the
premiere of mud bounds which is a segue
into my question actually because
everybody that I spoke to was like D is
amazing to work with she's absolutely
brilliant and I wondered as a director
if you had a particular process or you
had rituals that you used to kind of
build that trusting camaraderie I guess
yeah I just like to keep it more
conversational and I guess in the same
way I work with actors and small
pairings I work with the department
heads and small pairings like I'm not I
don't enjoy the big conference table
meetings you know you know which you
have to do with the ad a couple times
but I don't enjoy I don't feel that the
creative process is best served for
there you know I feel like it's in
one-on-ones I'm talking to the
production designer you know yeah the
cinematography needs to know that but
like later like I like to let the person
I like to complete the fire or complete
the idea or we're going to go through
three things that don't work before we
get the thing that does work and that
doesn't necessarily need to happen in
front of a department head you know cuz
then it'll say every people shut down or
then people are performing for each
other you know so I think it's my life
to work singly with people you know
versus like you know in a big group so
it's like collaboration one by one in a
weird way or you know in groups that
feel like you know more intimate where
things can bounce and grow without you
know getting cut off without being like
figure it out and yeah and just kind of
like very personal like sharing stuff
like filtering stuff like instead of
like dumping a big glut like here's all
my references like slowly like here some
songs that sound like the world and
here's some images that feel like the
world or here's a passage from a poem or
here's a thing so everyone feels like
they're getting like this personal a
little love note from me and then they
get inspired like you know like text
email like 3 o'clock in the morning like
I saw this passage or so you know so I
like to work in that way so it feels
like it's like the steady drip of kind
of like inspiration versus like this
kind of formalized roundtable thing you
know knights of the round table thing
and
yeah so maybe that and then I think
about to the question about writing
process like one of the things I do to
like in the writing of it you know so I
feel like you know you kind of vomit up
everything on a bunch of index cards not
necessarily an order but not just like
scenes but like ideas or sentences you
know those things that you know you want
in there but you don't know like where
they go yet and then when you start to
kind of figure out those sentences and
imagery arrange them in kind of arcs by
act and in writing it like I don't write
in sequence I write the two scenes I'm
most interested you know in that day and
for rewrites so for this thing and I
started off the page I started write
like what are the things that are not
there what are the scenes like that are
not there and so that was a easy way to
work back into how to incorporate it
into the script because sometimes you
start on the page you feel locked in
well this has to happen cuz it connects
to this and then that connects to that
but if you start off the page then
you're kind of freed of that and like
you know you're writing longhand and so
you're not bound to the connections and
you can figure out how to relink things
so yeah thanks I think Sean Baker may
have touched on this in his lecture than
that but the idea of the rewrite and
writing and that his script and past it
seen a similar view that's rewritten at
least three times that's rich rewritten
when you put it together it's rewritten
when you direct him and it's rewritten
when you only ever it is that you know
so actually I'm this a common saying
yeah totally yeah yeah yeah and I agree
with that and you have to stay open to
that yeah I think like when you're in
production you can't be married to the
words if the actor wants to add
something if we need a kind of entry
ramp or an exit ramp then you gotta
allow for that because it'll give it a
naturalism or and then and then in the
Edit room you know you got to kill your
darlings you can't like have a sentence
just because it's literary or cool like
is it character revealing or is it
moving the plot forward or is it setting
a tone and if not you know you have to
kind of kill it so then it's rewritten
again and even so even terms of
sequencing is rewritten in terms of what
best kind of gives the narrative
propulsion so totally yeah I'm and if we
can quickly touch on with what if you
know that you're doing next the next
project that you've got in the pipeline
yeah so the next is going to be about
the failure to ratify the Equal Rights
Amendment in the United States so I'm
tearing up the Carey Mulligan again
Civil War and so we're casting that now
and then I'm gonna do the last thing you
want it with Cassie Anna Joan Didion
adaptation which is exciting and so
again right it's like a it's on the
surface it's like the international spy
thriller but underneath it's really
about what happens when daughters trust
their fathers blindly you know you die
so and then and then the next thing I
want to do I really want to get away and
do this original Asaf I think I've been
just been gestating about you know we're
kind of environmental crisis meets you
know the economic crisis well all the
best with my bath oh and Jason Blum
we're gonna do a horror look how can I
forget like the me and Sarah are like
gonna write a horror story about what it
means to be you know black lesbians
living in like an all-white town it's
terrifying
thank you very much Terry thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]